hey 42 here let's have a peek inside
some of the most secretive places on
earth shrouded in mystery dens for the
rich and powerful where minds get
together and hatch shady plans these are
the places you're just not allowed to go
to room 39 North Korea as a whole is an
unnerving ly secretive place but there's
one room in one building that's the most
secretive of all room 39 established in
the late 1970s room 39 is a government
organization directly controlled by the
Kim family the goal of room 39 is to
seek underhanded and malicious ways to
illegally obtain foreign currencies it
is rumored that the organization
utilizes 10 to 20 bank accounts in China
and Switzerland for the purposes of
money laundering counterfeiting and
general shady transactions
it is widely speculated that room 39 is
deeply involved in government controlled
drug smuggling under licit weapon sales
we know that the organization has a
hundred and twenty foreign trade
companies under its jurisdiction nobody
knows how it got its name but the room
itself is said to be located inside a
ruling Workers Party building in the
capital city kayak club 33 somewhat less
malicious but just as secretive is
Disneyland's club 33 Club 33 is a
strictly Members Only Club and
restaurant discreetly located above the
Blue Bay Oh in New Orleans Square to
become a member and step inside to
notorious doorway you will need about
thirty thousand dollars what's even then
there's a for senior waiting list
there's a strict member limit of only
487 people the club has been frequented
by presidents prime ministers actors and
billionaires area 51 located in Southern
Nevada in the United States area 51 is a
large secretive military airfield and
arguably the most infamous and
controversial location in this video the
use of lethal force is authorized
if anyone attempts to step foot inside
the bases perimeter the bases primary
function is to develop ant
experimental aircraft and weapon systems
however because of the government's
incredibly tight grasp on the bases
secrecy area 51 has been the subject of
many UFO conspiracies many believe the
base is used to examine and attempt to
reverse-engineer crashed alien
spaceships alien technology and even
alien life-forms white gentlemen school
founded in 1693 by Frances white White's
is the most exclusive gentlemen's club
in existence White's is located in
London England and gained a reputation
for its exclusivity and often laddish
behavior of its members women are
completely banned from the club the only
woman to have ever been entertained by
the club is queen elizabeth ii the only
way to become a member of the club and
step inside the door is to first be a
man and second be invited by a current
member of the club who has the support
of two other members which unless your
best buddies with a member of the royal
family or a powerful politician isn't
likely to happen current notable members
include Prince Charles and Prince
William British Prime Minister David
Cameron was a former member for 15 years
but resigned in 2008 because he
disagreed with the club's male-only
policy the club is famous for its
betting book in which members make
outrageous bets such as a 3,000 pound
bet on which of to range ups would slide
down the window first RAF Menwith Hill
Menwith Hill is a Royal Air Force Base
in North Yorkshire England the primary
job of this mysterious RAF base is to
spy on and intercept enemy signals
satellites and missiles the base has
heavy connections with the global
echelons spy network the a Kalon Network
is a close-knit global spy alliance
between the United Kingdom United States
Canada Australia and New Zealand RAF
Menwith Hill is the largest electronic
monitoring station in the world and a
lot of its work is done on behalf of the
US National Security Agency it was
originally created during the Cold War
to spy on the Soviet Union and their
allies but it has since been used to spy
on terrorists and drug dealers it has
even been used to monitor and
intelligence on foreign political and
diplomatic bodies some believe it has
been heavily involved with commercial
espionage and mask eavesdropping on
telephone and radio communications mount
weather Emergency Operations Center deep
in the forests of the US state of
Virginia is a last resort base set up in
case an end-of-the-world situation ever
arises mount weather emergency operation
center was set up by Emma the Federal
Emergency Management Agency it is where
high-profile individuals and government
officials will shelter from impending
doom during an apocalypse very little is
known about the base because its details
are highly classified the base is
constantly protected by armed guards and
razor wire the complex consists of two
extremely large areas area a which is
above ground contained dormitories a
laboratory a training area and on-site
sewage treatment plant and two water
tanks holding 250,000 gallons of water
amongst many of her facilities it is
said the complex is completely
self-contained area B is entirely
underground some believe there was an
entire self-sustaining city below ground
that apparently consists of private
apartments streets and sidewalks
cafeterias and hospitals a power plant
an underground mass transit system under
TV network Mangia Mangia Mangia Montara
stat tallest mountain in the Ural
Mountains in Russia
standing at 1640 metres tall in the
local language mount yam on top means
evil mountain the US government strongly
believed that hidden deep within the
mountain is a massive stockpile of
nuclear weapons housed in underground
military facility there was a top-secret
town just south of the mountain called
this I'm not even going to attempt to
pronounce that the town is permanently
closed to the outside world
some believe the town contains a human
civilization employed to develop nuclear
weaponry the US government's how to
repeatedly US Russia what it's hiding
there and their answers are strangely
inconsistent over the years Russia has
said it's a mining site a repository for
Russian treasures
storage area and last but not least a
bunker for leaders in case of a nuclear
war
come on Russia make your mind up thanks
for watching until next time